I reached over and secretly undid my seatbelt.
And when his foot hit the brake at the red light,
I flung open the door and I ran.
I had no shoes on, I was crying.
I had no wallet, but I was okay because I had my cigarettes.
And I didn't want any part of freedom
if I didn't have my cigarettes.
When you live with someone who has a temper,
a very bad temper, a very, very bad temper,
you learn to play around that.
You learn this time I'll play possum
and next time I'll just be real nice
or I'll say yes to everything
or you make yourself scarce or you run.
And this was one of the times when you just run.
And as I was running, I thought
this was a great place to jump out
because they were big lawns and they were cul-de-sacs
and sometimes he would come after me
and drive and yell stuff at me to get back in, get back in.
And I was like, no, I'm out of here.
This is great and I went and hid behind a cabana
and he left and I had my cigarettes.
And I started to walk in this beautiful neighborhood.
It was 10.30 at night and it was silent and lovely
and there was no sound except for sprinklers.
Ch, ch, ch, ch, prrrr, ch, ch, ch, ch.
Prrrr, and I was enjoying myself
and enjoying the absence of anger
and enjoying these few hours I knew I'd have of freedom.
And just to perfect it, I thought I'll have a smoke
and then it occurred to me with horrifying speed,
I don't have a light.
Just then, as if an answer, I see a figure up ahead.
Who is that?
It's not him, okay?
They don't have a dog, who is that?
What are they doing out on this suburban street?
And the person comes closer and I can see it's a woman.
And then I can see, she has her hands in her face.
Oh, she's crying.
And then she sees me and she composes herself
and she gets closer and I see she has no shoes on.
She has no shoes on and she's crying
and she's out on this strange street.
I recognize her, though I've never met her.
And just as she passes me, she says, you got a cigarette?
And I say, you got a light?
And she says, damn, I hope so.
And then first she digs into her cutoffs in the front,
nothing, and then digs in the back
and then she has this vest on
that has 50 million little pockets on it
and she's checking and checking and it's looking bad.
It's looking very bad.
She digs back in the front again, deep, deep,
and she pulls out a pack of matches
that have been laundered at least once.
We open it up and there is one match inside.
Okay, oh my God.
This takes on, it's like Nassau now.
We gotta like, how are we gonna do it?
Okay, and we hunker down, we crouch on the ground
and where's the wind coming from?
We're stopping.
I take out my cigarettes, let's get the cigarettes ready.
Oh, my brand, she says, not surprising.
And we both have our cigarettes at the ready.
She strikes once, nothing.
She strikes again, yes, fire.
Puff, inhale, sweet kiss of that cigarette.
And we sit there and we're loving the nicotine
and we both need this right now.
I can tell, the night's been tough.
Immediately we start to reminisce
about our 30 second relationship.
I didn't think that was gonna happen, me neither.
Oh, man, that was close.
Oh, I'm so lucky I saw you, yeah.
Then she surprises me by saying, what was the fight about?
And I say, what are they all about?
And she said, I know what you mean.
She said, was it a bad one?
And I said, you know, like medium.
She said, oh, and we start to trade stories about our lives.
We're both from up north.
We're both kind of newish to the neighborhood.
This is in Florida.
We both went to college, not grade colleges,
but man, we graduated.
And I'm actually finding myself a little jealous of her
because she has this really cool job washing dogs.
She had horses back home and she really loves animals
and she wants to be a vet.
I'm like, man, you're halfway there.
I'm a waitress at an ice cream parlor.
So that's not, I don't know where I want to be,
but I know it's not that.
And then it gets a little deeper
and we share some other stuff about what our lives are like.
Things that I can't ever tell people at home.
This girl, I can tell her the really ugly stuff
and she still understands how it can still be pretty.
She understands like how nice he's gonna be
when I get home and how sweet that'll be.
We are chain smoking off each other.
Oh, that's almost out, come on.
And we go through this entire pack until it's gone.
And then I say, you know what, this is a little funny,
but you're gonna have to show me the way to get home.
Because although I'm 23 years old,
I don't have my driver's license yet.
And I just jumped out right when I needed to.
And she says, well, why don't you come back to my house
and I'll give you a ride.
I said, okay, great.
And we start walking.
And we get to this, lots of lights
and the roads are getting wider and wider
and there's more cars.
And I see lots of stores, you know, laundry mats
and dollar stores and emergency centers.
And then we cross over US-1
and she leads me to someplace and I think, no.
But yes, Carl's Efficiency Apartments.
This girl lives there.
And it's horrible and it's lit up so bright
just to illuminate the horribleness of it.
It's the kind of place where you drive your car right up
and the door's right there.
And there's 50 million cigarette butts outside.
And there's like doors one through seven
and you know behind every single door
there's some horrible misery going on.
There's someone crying or drunk or lonely or cruel.
And I think, oh, she lives here, how awful.
We go to the door, door number four,
and she very, very quietly keys in.
As soon as the door opens,
I hear the blare of television come out
and on the blue light of the television,
the smoke of 100 cigarettes in that little crack of light.
And I hear the man and he says, where were you?
And she says, nevermind, I'm back.
And he says, you all right?
And she says, yeah, I'm all right.
And then she turns to me and says, you want a beer?
And he says, who the fuck is that?
And she pulls me over and he sees me and he says,
oh, hey, I'm not a threat.
Just then he takes a drag of his cigarette,
a very hard, hard drag, you know,
the kind that makes the end of it really heat up,
hot, hot, hot and long and it's a little scary.
And I follow the cigarette down
because I'm afraid of that head falling off.
And I'm surprised when I see in the crook of his arm,
a little boy sleeping, a toddler.
And I think, and just then the girl reaches
underneath the bed and takes out a carton
and she taps out the last pack of cigarettes in there.
And on the way up, she kisses the little boy
and then she kisses the man and the man says again,
you all right?
And she says, yeah, I'm just gonna go out
and smoke with her.
And so we go outside and sit amongst the cigarette butts
and smoke and I say, wow, that's your little boy.
She says, yeah, isn't he beautiful?
And I say, yeah, he is, he is beautiful.
He's my light, he keeps me going, she says.
We finish our cigarettes.
She finishes her beer, I don't have a beer
because I can't go home with beer on my breath.
And she goes inside to get the keys.
She takes too long in there getting the keys
and I think something must be wrong
and she comes out and she says, look, I'm really sorry
but we don't have any gas in the car,
it's already on E and he needs to get to work
in the morning and I'm gonna walk to work as it is.
So what I did was though, here look,
I drew out this map for you and you're really,
you're like a mile and a half from home
and if you walk three streets over,
you'll be back on that pretty street
and you just take that and you'll be fine.
And she also has wrapped up in toilet paper,
seven cigarettes for me, a third of her pack, I note,
and a new pack of matches.
And she tells me goodbye and that was great to meet you
and how lucky and that was fun and let's be friends.
And I say, yeah, okay, and I walk away
but I kinda know we're not gonna be friends.
I might not ever see her again and I kinda know,
I don't think she's ever gonna be a vet.
And I cross and I walk away and maybe this would've seemed
like a visit from my possible future and scary
but it kinda does the opposite on the walk home.
I'm like, man, that was really grim over there.
And I'm going home now to my nice boyfriend
and he is gonna be so extra happy to see me
and we have a one bedroom apartment
and we have two trees and there's a yard
and we have this jar in the kitchen
where there's like loose money that we can use for anything
like we would never ever run out of gas
and I don't have a baby, you know?
So I can leave whenever I want.
I smoked all seven cigarettes on the way home
and people who have never smoked cigarettes
just think, ick, disgusting and poison.
But unless you've had them and held them dear,
you don't know how great they can be
and what friends and comfort and kinship they can bring.
It took me a long time to quit that boyfriend
and then to quit smoking.
And sometimes I still miss the smoking.
Then I stay away from him because of the work and the pain.
And even the